[音楽]
こんにちははめ社長です皆さんはカフェ
行ったことありますでしょうか日本には
ですね素敵なカフェたくさんあると思い
ますおしゃれなカフェとか昔風の喫茶店と
か味にこってるカフェとか逆に安さを追求
したカフェとか景色がいいカフェ定さんが
可愛いカフェ様々なカフェがこのようには
存在してるんですけれども私ですね今愛知
県の名古屋市のえとあるカフェに来ており
ますザベイクハウスっていう名前のカフェ
で普段は営業されてるんですけれども私
ネットの情報でこう入ってきたんです
けれども愛知県名古屋市にあるこの
カフェ世界一態度が悪いカフェらし
です消しかららん消しかららんよそんなの
接客あってこその飲食店もちろん無理に
ニコニコしろと言いませんがそのやはりお
客さんありきでこう対面のお店ってやっぱ
接客態度とかすごい大事だと思うんです
けれどもttokでもなんかよく流れて
くるんですけどもこのカめちゃくちゃ態度
悪いらしいです早速ちょっとその態度たる
や接客態度どんなもんなのかちょっと体験
してみたいと思います普段は18時から
営業されてるらしいんですけども特別に
あの貸し切りで撮影させていただいており
ますちょっと日中から行けるので期たい人
は皆さん18時降に来てくださいでは行き
ましょうで早速行きたいと思い
ますいらっしゃいませテザレイジハウスと
言いまして日本位客体の悪いレストランと
なっておりますこの扉をまいでいただき
ますと通常通りの接客になっておりますで
はご案内いたしますはいレイジ
ハウス行き
ます早く行け
早くて早く行けジャパクソイキ入り
ます早く行てはいおいパ
走れちる大丈夫どこでもいいから
行けすごい
発ここ座りますねやばい汗かってき
た走れって言わますめどくさいも
ダ
めんどくさいもの頼むなちょっと待っ
てあやばいやばい調理もすごいすねメニ
やばいっすよ友達が1お前のために店あげ
てやってんだから50万円分ぐらい食ない
50万円ちょっと待ってずメニュー表が
すごいんですよ作るの楽なやつどんどん
頼んでいいぞ友達が1人もいないお前らの
ために用意したマンゴーと生ハムの
カプレーゼトマトソースとチーズあとは
何かしらで作ったディップタコのウナしか
食べたことないやつに美味しいソーセージ
教えてやるネットに落ってたうまそうな
レシピを丸パクりしたクアドロフォルマッ
メニューに面倒だから頼むよって書いて
あります注文してみますねすいませ
ん座ってるすいませ
んった方がいいのかな注文っ
あ
前のペースで注文とかできないかそうです
よねすいませんいいいですかえっと
ドリンクどうしよっか
な
俺オレンジサンライズをおすすめとかあり
ますかはいじゃ11はいあじゃ11つで
友達が1人もいないお前のために用意した
ばなくていい遊いやさ
挟やぱ売り切れだしあてもお前には出さ
ないまこの辺かなおすすめあここら辺じゃ
1と2で
げ
はいこ
なんか緊張しますね逆にこういうのない
ですから
ね極悪みたいちょっとトイレ行きたくなっ
たんでトイレ行ってきます
ねトイレ借りてもいいです
かちょトイレ借てもいいです
か聞こえない聞こえないえないトイレ借り
てもいい店の目の前にバス走ってるから
それで名古屋駅まで行って名古屋駅の甲州
ベで
これかいですよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ねこれオレンジサンライですねちょっと先
にいただきます
[音楽]
うまい悔しいけどうまい
ですちょっと間結構来てから立ってます
ちょっと聞いてみましょうかどれぐらい
すいませんあとどれぐらいかかれそうです
ですかね知ら
ない何がいいたいの遅いってことあいや
そういうわけでは時間気になったなって
全然ゆっっくりで大丈夫ですよ
ねこれ美味しい
なやばい喋ん
ない
[音楽]
いやめちゃくちゃうそうちゃんと作って
くれて
だナイスが欲しかったらこれ削っ
てくいただきます
うめえ接客態度とか全く関係なく本当に
美味しいですこれサ休憩からもしばらく
料理出てこないと思う
休憩
タバコ
[音楽]
めちゃ
たでした出てこなった出てこ
ない次の
メニーのるあ大丈夫です
はい
有名なYouTuberなんだろあそう
こんなことさ聞いてもいい願してもいい
いつ帰ってくれ
のいつ帰ってくれ
あ変
な届きました
食べるもの
がない
ですこのジップでいいんですよすいません
はいこれって普通にもうリップで手で食べ
ちゃって大丈夫リップで
食べる逆にどうやって食べる
のいやスプンでパン作ってそれでリップし
て食べだったらいいよスあげるけどどう
するあ大丈夫ですリップで食べ
ますいただき
ますうま味は最高です味は早く食べないと
怒られちゃう見て
ください真ん中の卵をどうすればいいん
ですかねこれディップできないあのさ常識
的に考えて食デザート感どればいいあじゃ
これをロータス品のロータスでロータ
はいじゃそうですね常識的に頼んだ方が
いいですよねデザート
[音楽]
はもてがあそうですね飲み物もなくなり
ましたもんねあのデザートと一緒になんか
飲み物とかももらっていいです
か何カフェラテとかいいのあカフェラテで
お願いし
[音楽]
ますこれ洗にせ
風
アヒビールき
ますうまいちょっとこれ食べたいすよね
すいませんはいパンがなくなってディップ
できなくなっちゃったんです
けどスプーン買ってお借りしてもいいです
かパンのスカじゃなくてスプーンあじゃ
パンのスイカでお願いしますはいさはい
パンは
上さ
れこげこげで
あれげはい8性物質入りましたありがとう
ございますやば
すぎる聞かてから
あ
急で食べます
ねあすいませんスプーンもらいます
かあありがとうござい
ますはいありがとうございますあ
ありがとうございます
そ挨拶大きい声でしたよ
はい行きましょうかごました食べるのすぎ
あすいません変てあすいませんちょっとお
買いてお願いし
[音楽]
ます
札知てそう顔だからさもう帰ってすいませ
ご様でし
た
早くやばいやばいやばい出ろ
[音楽]
ち狂ってるしありがとうございましあ
ありがとうございましたあちょっと直った
ござありがとうござい出たら治るんですね
はいわかり子なんであそうなんですね
ありがとうございましためた
こわいやありがとうございました失礼し
ません本当にいやとんでもないとんでも
ない途中からガチなんかなと思っちょっと
怖くなっ全1mmもガチじゃないですこれ
すなまた待してますあありがとうござい様
でし
た店から出たら切り替わるんですねいや
すごいわこういうコンセプトで多分やっ
てると思うんですけど分かっててもやっぱ
ちょっとドキドキしちゃいますねあいう
ことされるとすごいせめっちゃ怖くて嫌
だったんですけどちゃんと美味しかったの
で良かったですなんか接客の大切さを
改めてなんか感じました
ねでえ今ですね私はじめ社長はこういう
コセのカフェだってきたんですけども今
からですね後輩を何も知らせないままこの
世界度の悪いカフェに連れててちょっと
どういう感じになるのか見てみたいと思い
ますでは早速連れてきます地獄のそ
どうぞしますはいで行こうぜはい
なかしめっちゃおいしいのよこの
食いいですか入ってどうぞどうぞ失礼し
ます
あ
[音楽]
こ
あれれ
てこっちどこでもいいから
行けここですか
ね
注文いいです
[音楽]
か
やすいませ
んあちいですかあはい
えっと友達が1人もいないってすいません
番1番と8
番と飲み物なんかおすすめとかあります
自分で考えてはいオレンジ
サンライズ2つお願いし
[音楽]
ます
ビゴソ思いしちゃっ
たありがとうござい
[音楽]
ますすいません何頼んでもいいですかそ
から
覚えオレンジサンライズとオレンジ
スって違い教えてもらってもいいです
[音楽]
かオレンジサンライズとオレンジジュース
の違いを教えてくださいわかんない頼む
なすませ逆にこのオレンジジュースこの下
の赤いの何なんだサライか
[音楽]
やろオレンジジュースお願いしますお前
最終学小学校か
お一応大学でき
ます
お店のブラスと相談したんだけどぱお前は
髪にっ
たありがとうござい
ますめちゃくちゃりなっと
うん貧乏そうだから大にしていた
今全員アスそうな
アどうしまし
たあごめんマジでお客さんに早く帰って
もらいたい時これやっちゃうくせ
あるまだ結構残ってますお前残した殺す
[音楽]
[拍手]
から
おするかびれたからさ気分の上がる音楽
かけてもいいあお願いしますBGMかけて
いい
[音楽]
はい美しかったですあもう帰るだ全然て
くれててあ本当ですかいやでもすごい感応
できました
本当ちょっと待っておするから
[音楽]
はい
てまったき
ます
ですおいしかったですお前風呂入れよカ洗
よはい持ってきます髪洗っ
た
怖と泣きそう
ですありがとうございましたえ怖い怖い
わまだますか
全髪の毛切れないからあだからずっとそれ
で匂いをいじりそう不潔に見えたのかも
しれないいやえ頑張ってスプレーとかやっ
てるんですけどいや本当に味はすごい
うまいんすけどちょっと怖かった早く帰り
たかっ
た
え今日何ですかご飯ですか今日
ご飯めちゃくちゃ美味しいはいカフェが
あったのでカフここですかここですえ
おしゃれめっちゃおしゃれでしょおしゃ
れっす静岡にはないどうぞどうぞ
はい失礼しますあれこれは早く
[拍手]
行けそうすどこどこで奥奥はい失礼し
ます美味しそっす美味しそうだはいクソ店
入りまし
たなん
[音楽]
でマジちょっとト見くるはい
全いらっしゃいましお突然の質問で申し訳
ないんですけどいつ変えられますかはい
いつ変えられるえっとなるべく早めにお
願いしますはいすいません
いつ
うすますここ客は貧乏にしかいないと思う
ので
出してないけどマイリストも一応あるから
欲しかったら来る
かひどい店ななせ
な聞こえちゃたすいませ
ん
あれあ注文いいです
かいいですや
ばお願いしますなか呼んでれば
いい
働いて
ください何あオレンジジュースいあと
レモネードください初出だから全部頼んで
全部っ部てはいあ頼んであ誰めっちゃいい
お店じゃないいやいいすけど癖がいいいお
店いいお店すねすいませ
んすいませ待ってろ
はい
おおごめなさい注文する時さはい空気
読むあ注文はいいすかそのまで行って
えっと5番お願いします5番はいピザ何回
すればいいの
えっと6ぐらいでお願いし
ます頼みましたあ美味しそうじゃ
そうぐらい5番ピザていあピザピザ頼んだ
やつ
はい声がちっちゃいえピザ頼んだやつはい
違うえピザ頼んだやつはいはい私ですはい
私ですもう1回はい私です
最初からす美味しそうだな美味しそうっす
ねでもカット
はちょ6ピースあるかだけあ確かに
1234あ5だあこいやいや2じゃない6
だねんだこれなんかあるのかいや数えて
みろわかんだえ確かにいやこうなんか綺麗
に来るかなっていうに
私えどっちが頭弱いのお前そのピザの隠し
何か
わかるですかうまいだろうまい隠し何か
分かる菓がわかんないと思うけど考えてみ
バジ違う当たり前だ入ってん
[音楽]
だスパイスはわかりまし
たれ蜂蜜とか違蜂蜜死ねえ
なピント教えてやろうかお願いしますま
一般的にはウイルスって言われてる思
ウイルス一般的にやなあコロナは
あのあるじゃないですかビールねああも
あああのなんか勝利して全然違うじゃ直す
こと成功してやろうかはい一般的に
ウイルス言われてるわかんない分かんない
インフ違病
よく知ってる
わたすごいこと言えどうしたどうしたい
なんかこれ隠し屋でなるだと思い
ます隠し屋隠し屋であるらします
えじゃない知ってんす
[音楽]
か
お食べたかじゃおかき行くか呼んできた方
がいい多分こっちそうはいあすいません
食べ終わったんすけどお会計いいです
[音楽]
かすいませ
ん
おおおですはいじゃ速帰るはいありがとう
ございまし
たひ
すぎすいせありがとうございましたあり
ござありがとうございましたございささん
ありがとうございましありがとうござい
ましたえ世界一タイトの悪いカフェです
うわあガチっすかこれはガチガチの店です
かいガチの店ですよねはい全然特別扱いし
てないですえええエキストラでもないって
ことですか店員
です何いいこれ焦
[音楽]
て